foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsey
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money I'm George Campbell Join This Hour
by my good friend Mr Ken Coleman and we
are excited to take your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life your money your work how
it all connects and uh Ken is especially
excited to take those work calls
especially passionate about those
because too many people in America can
are frustrated with their careers
frustrated with their incomes and you
give them hope every single day that's
right you know you're not limited you
you are not limited to a good job to an
average job you're not limited
financially you still live in the
greatest economic engine the world has
ever produced and so we want to
encourage you and equip you to get there
you can make a change if you're in the
baby steps you can it's possible so when
we're together it's always fun because
we can talk about money and work and as
Davis said for decades your income is
your greatest wealth building tools so
you want to increase your income uh you
got questions around that I'm your guy
and it's always good to be with you uh
we're fresh off of the plane that's
right incredible crowd last night in
Minneapolis Minnesota Building Wealth
live we were there we just got in came
straight from the airport uh here
because we're the hardest working men in
Show Business that's right how it is
there it is we had a good time about 5
000 of them out there and the people in
Minnesota are just salt of the earth
very nicest warmest people well they're
happy to be inside let's be honest it's
cold out there I mean it was 60 degrees
uh uh to the day before and it got down
into the 40s and then we woke up this
morning walked outside to get in the car
28 degrees no thanks happy to be back
here in Tennessee yeah taking your calls
all right let's get to the line
Sebastian kicks us off in Chicago
Chicago Sebastian welcome to the show
hey y'all how are you doing today we're
doing great how can we help
yeah so um I've been kind of floundering
around trying to figure out what to do
with my life and I think I boiled it
down to like a fundamental question uh
do I do something for a cause that I can
get behind but I don't really enjoy the
daily work of or do I do something that
I enjoy uh the work of you know daily
but I would have difficulty getting
behind the purpose of and I'm generally
a purpose-driven person so I kind of I
think I would struggle with doing just a
job I merely enjoy but wouldn't really
be able to get behind and then the last
few days I have kind of like maybe
narrowed it down to something that I can
get behind both uh but I've also like
changed my mind a lot so I I don't know
if that's uh certain yeah well if if
there's one thing I'm certain of it's
you are uncertain my friend and thank
you yeah it's okay it's okay we're gonna
help you with that
so I want to know this idea where you
say you could do both because that's
what I teach and you've created a false
choice
do something that the work itself I
enjoy but the results of the work don't
connect to my values or do something
where the values the results of the work
connect but I don't enjoy the work
that's a false choice I actually teach
that we as humans are on purpose doing
what we were created to do when we use
what we do best
to do work we love
to produce results that matter to us so
what's this third idea this idea you've
been kicking around where you think you
can do both
do the work you love and connect to the
results what is it
'd be like a university professor of
government philosophy and economics okay
tell us why that would be work that you
love focus on the work itself
okay uh like the the daily in and out
yeah what about that job as being a
professor of government would be work
that you love
uh first of all I love teaching people
things it's something I'm passionate
about I'm also uh phenomenal at studying
that's what I did throughout my own uh
University career so I'd also have the
opportunity to study myself and then
teach others and engage them um in a in
a way that would really challenge them
to think like I could go in and teach
something like math which is probably
what I enjoy the most but but it's not
something that I could really like get
behind but something with government and
economics uh you have the opportunity to
shape uh young minds and challenge
others to think about the way that
Society is constructed think away think
about the way that governments are set
up and ask the questions like is this is
what we're doing the best way uh for the
people okay and that's especially
because I've seen and I've been to other
countries where it's just a mess you
know okay so you answered my next
question which is what results what are
the values that that position would
allow you to connect with and you just
went ahead and answered that so if you
look at what I just said to you when you
use it you do best to do work you love
to produce results that matter you
you're on fire you're on purpose and you
ex you experience extreme fulfillment
and so those three elements are Talent
passion and Mission
I'm using my talent to perform my
passion to accomplish my mission does
that make sense to you
use my talent
um
to Roar my passion it's a yes or no
question I'm going to say it again Dan
it's as simple as it gets my young
friend who wants to teach if I use my
talent to perform my passion to
accomplish my mission does that make
sense to you
that makes sense all right then does the
college professor of government and
economics allow you to do that yes or no
and this is something that's like I I
think so we're so close what do you mean
you think so what do you mean you think
so no you you no no
what now here's where the problem comes
in
your thinking instead of feeling
I'm not saying that's the only job for
you where you can do that but if we look
at college professor of government and
economics we have to run it through that
grid
it doesn't mean it's the only job for
you but it allows you to go could I do
that well would I enjoy it and would it
produce results that matter to me what's
the answer yes or no
I I guess it's the best thing that I've
come across so far you know the answer
is yes or no would that job allow you to
fulfill I'm not saying you got to choose
it I'm saying would it meet the
requirement yes or no
the answer is yes the answer is yes just
say yes for a second then I'm going to
lead you further yes or no sure yes all
right now now what we have to do is we
say okay that one seems to check all the
boxes but I'm gonna go do the work of
clarifying and verifying and here's what
that means you need to actually spend
some time with a college professor
coffee lunch talk to them learn
everything about the ins and outs of
that job The Good The Bad George the
ugly and when you do that Sebastian that
will then allow you to go ding ding ding
or does that make sense yes or no
that makes sense all right see now we're
not so locked up right
yeah you don't have to get off this
phone call and choose college professor
but I gave you a process by which you
can know with tremendous Clarity and
confidence that this is what I want to
do that's been your jam you you've been
all stuck on uncertainty and I just gave
you a process so go spend time with
college professors and if it's a no then
we keep using that purpose statement
plan let's give him by the way the get
clear assessment hang on the line
Sebastian we're going to give you a tool
that's going to give you a great high
level job description it's called the
get clear assessment more of your calls
coming up triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour and we are here for you
America give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Fallon
joins us up next in Fresno California
Fallon welcome to the show how you doing
I'm great thanks for having me on yeah
what's going on
so I am currently on workers pump I'm a
surgical assistant and I got hurt before
I got hurt I was looking for another job
it is just a I love what I do but the
culture the environment I'm just I
wasn't very happy there
um I have gone on an interview and
actually have an opportunity to take a
position
but I'm Sean workers comp so do I
uh put in my two week notice do I get
off I don't know what to do now
well are there any terms that say you
can't put in your two weeks while you're
on workers comp
uh no there's nothing like that
um the they put me on light duty but the
light duty that I have
um just coincides with working as a
surgical assistant but it doesn't
coincide with
um this new job that I'm applied for and
got the offer for so what's the start
date of the new job
but I didn't tell them
um the new job that I'm on uh disability
and I just said you know uh can I get at
least give them a two week so I have two
weeks to kind of figure this out and I
want to go out respectfully I don't are
you able to burn any Bridges no I get it
are you able to start this new job in
two weeks or are you still disabled
um well this is a non-issue something
and Pops my shoulder out well then you
shouldn't be taking workers comp if
you're fine and you should resign and
you should resign well so you should put
your two weeks in
I'm not even sure I understand really
the heart of your question if I if I've
got details you're are you worried
you're going to lose the workers comp by
taking the new job
no I'm worried uh because I well I had a
doctor's appointment today I tried to
get off workers comp and they said give
it another week
yeah but so I'm I'm trying I've been
trying to get off and they keep telling
me well you know you can't grasp or grip
anything I'm like but I can who's there
who's the doctors uh the the doctor the
workers comp doctor mind you the same
doctor hasn't looked at me in the eye
the past four weeks I've been in there
okay so all right thank you for sharing
that so here this is very simple
Fallon you're in charge
you go in today today's Friday I'd give
my two weeks today
and then they'll decide on the workers
comp it's not up to you but you don't
need workers comp if the workers comp
doctor is not looking in the eye and
whatever nonsense is going on there none
of that's relevant to what you should do
you're ready to start this new job in
two weeks yes or no
yes yes is there an underlying fear
of taking this new job and putting your
two weeks
honestly I think it's more of a like
internal like I haven't told anybody I'm
looking for a job and I've been using so
is it yeah I've been using yeah kind of
why I I mean what are you guilty of tell
me tell me something that you've done
wrong
I mean I even asked
for a day off
another job like I just feel bad
okay I just feel like it's not I'm not
having the Integrity that I do have but
I
I hate the position I'm in right now did
you do something did you do something
ethically or morally wrong when you
asked for the day off did it was it a
paid day off paid vacation
uh yeah I did a PTO was it part of your
package
yes yeah did you do anything morally or
ethically or legally wrong
no all right then
the right thing to do is to quit With
Honor today and be kind and say hey
here's the deal I found another job
that's just much better for me and
appreciate this opportunity and I'm
giving you my two weeks notice
you're a good person but you're worried
about something you shouldn't worry
about
okay and Fallon there is more Integrity
in you leaving well than you staying at
a place where your heart is Left Right
and your body needs to go with it now
and so I know it it hurts it's like a
breakup when you leave a job there's
people that you care about there they've
treated you well for the most part it
sounds like and so the guilt is coming
from the sense of I owe them something
because they gave me a job correct
yeah that's exactly it right so what I'm
telling you is you've done nothing wrong
that's why I walked you through those
questions you just said you've done
nothing wrong so therefore a person who
has done nothing wrong should not be
guilty what's really happening is you're
worried about what they're going to say
about you or think about you but you got
to choose you got to choose your future
and your life and not worry about what
people are going to say about you am I
right
yeah
I know and as a fellow people pleaser it
is easier said than done yeah
these are two but I'm gonna tell you
something I'm going to choose a better
life as opposed to worry about giving
everybody the greatest impression well
I'll tell you what it turns into casting
it turns into resentment yeah when it
sits too long yeah resign today
okay yeah that's what I'm doing then uh
that's resign instead of resent yes you
hear the relief on her oh we just the
weight on her shoulders yeah it was a
lot yeah she's a good person and
absolutely all right let's go on to
Atlanta Georgia Braden joins us there
Braden welcome to the show
hey how are you doing doing great how
can we help today
yes sir so uh I'm 20 years old I'm
looking to enroll in flight school and
the flight school that I'm looking at is
going to be 65 000 and I'm curious if it
would be better to take out a loan right
now and go ahead and do it or to get a
job and try to save up over three or
four years to save the money and then
pay it off and then go to the flight
school then
I think you know the answer Brighton
don't you
what is your heart what does your heart
say to do
you do it now
and what does your mind say to do
are they saying different things is that
where this tension is coming from
yes in a way what are you doing right
now
like right this looks like in my life
yeah
um I had a part-time job at my church
and then I do doordash on the side
um yeah but you've have you always had
this dream of uh flying uh for the past
couple years awesome
well yeah you called into our show we'll
give you our opinion and that is to wait
in cash flow it because when you go to
flight school and take loans out to do
it it's going to be a burden that's
going to hold you back it's going to
hold you down
okay but when you do with cash number
one I think it's going to accelerate the
dream because you really want this which
means you're willing to do whatever it
takes to cash flow if we say hey debt is
off the table and the only way you can
fly is if you pay cash for this flight
school would you be able to do it faster
than three or four years
at 65 000 so I don't know maybe I think
yes the answer is yes if you are willing
to wait and to put this out there say
I'm going to cash flow it you watch your
intensity increase you go get yourself a
really good full-time job that's making
way more money than you're making at
your church and doordash and all of a
sudden we accelerate this plan the more
you want it the faster you'll go get it
this is a fact
okay
so are you you're working part-time with
the church could you get a different
full-time job that pays more
yes probably okay and so that would be
my next step is how do we increase
income so that this isn't a four-year
journey and instead it's a two-year
journey and by the way I'm still getting
experience along the way and maybe I can
start the program once I know I can cash
flow the remainder of it yeah and I and
I've got another suggestion I'd get a
different full-time job that makes way
more I don't even care if it's related
to anything you love in fact even if you
hate it a little bit it's probably good
because it'll make you even more fired
up to get out of that but I also
recommend that you have a part-time job
working in a private airport or at the
airport get in the industry it's the
proximity principle I wrote an entire
book on this I'm going to give it to you
as my gift today so uh we'll put you on
hold here in a second and give you that
book but you need to be in that world
creating connections which will lead to
Opportunities so that when you finally
get that final qualification you should
have a gig waiting on you um
we'll send that over to you and wishing
you the best but I'm telling you man you
talked to anyone who has taken out
student loans for the dream and the
dream starts to fizzle because now they
have to pay someone at the end of every
month regardless of whether they finish
the program or not and it really taints
this dream that you once had of flying
and when you do it with cash man you're
gonna rest easy and uh you're gonna be
flying high all puns intended thanks for
the call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined this hour by the
host of the Ken Coleman show you guessed
it Ken Coleman himself is here with us
we're taking your questions about life
money work the pursuit of happiness the
American dream you made us
well you just mentioned the American
dream and I think we need to point out
that that dream is still intact
because of our men and women who have
served us and protect that freedom
absolutely to pursue happiness and here
it is Veterans Day so I just uh I don't
know when you said that I thought well
let's just thank those men and women who
who have served us because that is a
huge sacrifice so thank you all yes we
are so blessed by our service men and
women out there sacrificing for our
country every day and one of them is in
the booth with us our very own Austin on
the phones that's running all the phone
screening today is the veteran himself
you know what I'm very grateful I'm
going to salute him through the glass I
don't know if that's the proper angle
thank you Austin but uh there it is
thank you sir all right let's get back
to the phones Carter joins us in
Richmond Virginia up next Carter welcome
to the show
hey thanks for having me how are you
guys we're doing great what's going on
with you
um so I am 19.
um I graduated high school last year I'm
not planning to go to college and this
year I'll plan to make about 40 000 with
my job I'm in right now I make about 30
000 in uh doing Contracting and about 10
000 on the side hustle uh do you mind
Connor I just wanna I wanna brag on you
uh because that's really good money for
a 19 year old what kind of Contracting
are you doing
uh we do like house remodels editions
right so you went straight out of high
school into that huh pretty much yep you
enjoy it
oh I do yeah it's great yeah go make a
lot of money aren't you yeah we do all
right all right sorry I selfishly took
over the call that's great I'm sending a
little subtle message to parents Across
America there go ahead Sir with your
question
um I'm just wondering um with with that
experience in getting there um I would
really like to buy and uh flip a house
and have it for myself here but I'm just
wondering um is it too soon for me to uh
be able to buy am I going to be able to
get approved for a loan or do I need to
wait um if so how long I'm trying to get
married in probably about three years or
so uh two or three years so I'm not sure
if I should wait till after that to buy
a house but I'd love to buy a house and
be able to fix it up um and then be able
to get married and move into it well I
love your drive I love that you have
these kinds of goals at 19 years old and
I think you're going to get there so how
much money do you have currently saved
uh really not much I just had to buy a
car with cash so I kind of took away oh
boy the savings I had for that
um so I'm just now kind of starting to
get back and trying to save a lot for
that um how much I I'm from the I'm from
Virginia and I lived in Richmond for a
year so I'm just curious how big of a
house and how much are you thinking
I'm not not big probably a thousand
value 2000 at the very most
um in the area I'm at there are plenty
for sale right now around that for about
200 to 300 000 in a great area
um I work for my parents right now and
I'm looking kind of in the area where
we're at and
um yeah so probably probably about 200
000 about I don't know 1200 square feet
yeah well I I think you're you're onto
something here having much more focused
goals and that's what we teach when it
comes to goal setting is we want it to
be specific measurable in writing yours
and you're doing that by saying three
years from now I want to purchase a 250
000 house how much do I need to be
saving to be able to put down to qualify
for the loan and we have very specific
parameters that I think there's a lot of
wisdom to it and that is don't do
anything but a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage where the payment is no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
and what's great is that helps dictate
how much down payment you need to have
so for some people that might be 50 for
some it might be 20 for some it might be
10 percent
but I think a guy as young as you who's
that already so successful I would aim
for 20 on a 200 000 house at least and
uh your income is going to go up over
the next three years am I right
yeah yeah I think the cap is with my
current employers about 50 000 a year
what's the cap about five houses
uh he's just my boss told me that um
with uh the work and stuff I can't make
more than uh 25 an hour interesting okay
well I mean that may be true I mean that
you know he that he gets to decide that
that's the free market but you're not
capped you may be capped in that job but
you are not cap my friend you know that
yeah
so I so that's that's why I'm trying to
pick up these side hustles here doing
handyman and other things to be able to
make up that extra you know 10 20 a year
yes sir yes heat that up for another
three years I would wait until you're
married if that's on the horizon in the
next three years because you need that
time to save up anyways
okay and so I would jump onto
ramseysolutions.com you can use our
mortgage calculator and that will help
dictate exactly what your down payment
goal is so you have something to aim for
over the next three years and that will
also fuel you in your side jobs and your
work you're doing every day and uh you
know with putting a ring on and getting
married what an exciting time for you
mm-hmm yeah
you feel good about this Carter I think
so I think so and one one other
clarifying question
um
you know if uh if I need to have
um you know you're saying 20 percent
um down of the total house or 20 of my
income that would be of the purchase
price of the home
okay okay of your income it would be 25
of your take-home pay so you're after
after you pay Uncle Sam uh whatever's
left of that 25 should be allocated to
that mortgage payment at the most too
and so if that payment is looking like
35 40 you don't have enough margin to do
other things like invest and save up for
a car and have fun and go on vacation
unless I forget Carter you want to fix
this thing up so you're going to buy
something that's that's got more value
once you put your Blood Sweat and Tears
into the house so George is absolutely
right waiting longer is okay because
you're always going to be able to get
something like that number one number
two you're not married yet that's off in
the distance and you can save up easily
the Forty thousand on a two hundred
thousand dollar that gives you your 20
you need to save up more in my opinion
because that gives you the cash that you
need to come in and fix it up and you
knowing what the prices are of materials
you doing a lot of the work yourself or
you've probably got some buddies who are
Tradesmen who may be special as they
come in I mean I know how this works so
you need some extra cash to get the
house where you want it so that when
your new wife comes in
you carry Across the Threshold he
probably doesn't even know what that is
threshold you know it's a it's a much
better house so patience is the play
here you know yeah and with the current
market though that things are kind of
not stale I guess yet but you don't
think you don't think I should go now
but I should wait no no you don't have
the money now George just walked you
through that and never never try to time
the market because truthfully we don't
know what it's going to do and so I'd
much rather have this piece under my
control and go when I can financially
afford this to where it's a blessing and
not a curse that's when I'm ready to buy
a house regardless of what the market is
doing
and that's a very freeing feeling
because you're not stressed thinking
about what's going to happen with the
market six months from now what if I got
a bad deal because six months later it
went down I could have got a better deal
man with your skill set you're gonna
find a deal on a fixer-upper deal passed
on that's we're going to turn that thing
into a Butte in no time oh look at that
I love it George I love when you go all
Northern on us that's a beaut that's a
beaut Clark uh I'm bada bing bada boom
he's got a house in no time and Carter I
love I love the energy Ken I love young
people yeah who have this level of
maturity and drive I I was trying to
stay out of the way and let you help the
young man but I just want to brag on him
and again paint another picture for
American parents and kids
for 40 or 50 years we've been shoved a
marketing message from culture coming
from the federal and state governments
and higher ed has been shoving a message
down our throats that college is the
only way to success and you got kids
like Carter who doesn't want to darken
the door of college he doesn't need to
go to college and thankfully he didn't
go to college what did he do he went to
work and he's good at it and he's 19 and
he's calling us he just paid cash for a
car and I would say the majority of his
19 year old friends in that Richmond
Virginia area have gone to school and
they're borrowing money to get a degree
they can't use and don't want to use
but here's an alternative a Tradesman at
19. I'm tired of people looking down
their nose at the trades and parents
being embarrassed to say my kid didn't
go to college he went to work and that's
a good thing yeah I love this let's skip
the name brand school to get the
Philosophy degree so that a parents can
feel good about themselves and yet the
kid has no job opportunity at the end of
that none they're strapped with student
loan debts and going wait you guys
screwed me over you lied and we've got
to stop this and it starts with the
parents you're so right Ken more of your
calls coming up on the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well folks it is Veterans Day and today
we want to celebrate and honor all of
you who have served in our military so
get this if you're listening today and
you're a veteran thank you thank you
from the bottom of our hearts for your
service and for your sacrifice and on
Monday we announce we are giving away
Financial Peace University for free to 1
000 veterans but so many of you reached
out that we decided to do it again today
so here's the deal if you are a veteran
just go to ramseysolutions.com Veterans
you'll fill out one simple form and our
team will reach out to you and help you
get set up with Financial Peace
University for free reminder we're doing
this just for today on Veterans Day for
up to 1 000 veterans right now go to
ramseysolutions.com Veterans and get
Financial Peace University for free
and again from all of us from Ken
Coleman and I from the entire Ramsay
Solutions team thank you so much for
serving our country by the way more good
news for veterans I just saw this today
we're now seeing a trend with companies
are reaching out to Veterans and
aggressively looking to hire veterans oh
I love that uh because uh veterans don't
mind coming into the office as much and
dealing with more stressful situations
where you have a lot of people that have
left the workplace to kind of go work
from home and so they're finding that
veterans are filling that hole and there
still is a large gap in the American job
economy right now where unemployment's
still low about 3.8 percent which is
almost historically low and uh just just
a little bit less than a job and a half
available for every person who's
unemployed wow so still a big need to
fill jobs uh even with inflation being
high so it's good to see veterans who
have so much to offer when they leave
the military but many times feel as
though
that they don't have as much to offer
because they've only worked in the
military and of course that couldn't be
they're so valuable so incredible and
you did a whole segment on this uh was
it on Fox Ken we did an entire hour last
year uh on Fox Business called from
military to Marketplace and so I do want
to point out to reach out to the Ken
Coleman show listen call me if you are a
veteran and you feel or you're going to
be retiring from the military soon and
you feel like uh what do I do now please
call the show I I would I will clear the
decks to talk with you and help you see
how your skills and experience can be
transferable to the marketplace I love
it and by the way if you know a veteran
who would love to get Financial Peace
University for free tell them about this
tell them to go to ramseysolutions.com
Veterans today and we're giving that to
1 000 people awesome all right let's go
to the phones and joins us in Knoxville
Tennessee and welcome to the show
thank you is an honor and a pleasure to
speak with you guys I appreciate you
taking my call oh we feel the same way
how can we help today
um yes I am
I scared poopless as I may say because
um uh growing up
um my parents had a lot of money um some
of the wrong reasons and my mom had
passed away
um December of last year
um between life insurance and the money
cash she had in the bank was about 400
and votes um about 430 000 so we bought
a decent sized home paid us all our
debts and
um uh we've had our three to six month
emergency fund
um I am now at my mom's house up for
sale
um and we um we're just nothing to get
an offer tonight we have the high school
system for 887 but here comes in my
question
um I I save but sometimes I do go on a
spending spree my husband's a spender
he's a disabled conduct veteran and I
have this is dearly special needs
daughter and I how do I just keep that
money and to grow it and not like want
to have a touchdown
um
well I I appreciate the self-awareness
that you have to even go listen I have a
spending problem and I want to be a good
Steward of what was entrusted to me and
so that is truly the first step is just
wanting that
and most people in your boat they just
go well I'm just going to spend it and
I'm gonna have nothing to show for it
and the Legacy that was left to me is
now gone and so there's a lot of things
you can do with this that will kind of
force you to not spend it all and one of
those is to put it somewhere where you
can't see it and you can't touch it so
have you worked with a team around this
money do you have a good Tax Advisor a
good insurance agent a good investment
professional a good tax attorney I don't
have any of that I have a good Rabbi who
chooses your products and the older
editors and the dog uses your kinds of
services
um but we were waiting until we get the
money and I'm just worried as I wait I'm
already going to come up with a million
ideas of oh this person could use the
money in the congregation this person
could use it you know as you did like I
want to give a lot of money to my Rabbi
and just like hold on I want to put the
brakes on and freeze so I talked to a
couple of trust people but
um I I just don't know what way is the
right way because I don't want to get
into the wrong
um I don't want to get scammed out of
something because this is a lot of money
at stake and this can definitely change
my children's lives especially my
daughter who may never be able to move
out on her own absolutely well and
people will come out of the woodwork
when they find out you got a big Lumber
with cash and so that is why you need to
be extra intentional about protecting
this and at ramsaysolutions.com you can
click on Ramsay recommends and we have
pros and all of these categories that
can walk with you that have the heart of
a teacher that we vet that you can trust
to help you make the right decisions and
by the way they don't make any decisions
for you if anyone tries to make it
decision for you they don't have your
best interest at heart and so that is
red flag number one
so get a good tax Pro in your corner get
a good investing Pro in your corner and
get a good insurance agent in your
corner and that is going to help you all
this are you working with a good real
estate agent on the sale of the house
um I believe I am
land and there's
stuff you were doing like for sale by
owner to try to you know cut some money
no no no no but as long as you're
working with a program okay so on the
other side of this coin you're saying
Hey I want to give a bunch of it I want
to spend there's only three things you
can do with money you can give it you
can save it and you can spend it and I
encourage you to do all of those things
in ratios with this money
so that's what I think your homework is
to do is to sit down and go what are the
ratios here do we want to give 10 of
this uh you said you don't have any debt
now
including the house well we have a small
land that but that
um we're um actually selling that
um but that's only like 26 a month okay
yeah I just want to jump in here to say
I appreciate that you've got this fear
but that is coming from a place of a
mindset to where you feel like you might
be foolish with this as opposed to going
I'm not going to be foolish with this
and I don't believe you I know I know I
know but that's not who you are that's
not who you are and that's what I'm
getting at I want to challenge you to
say wait a second I get a fresh start
here this is what I did in the past and
I've learned from that because you
certainly have
and and now it's about going I'm going
to be intentional before I was emotional
with money now I'm going to be
intentional with money and I think it's
replacing not just the word but
replacing the mindset to go not anymore
I have been blessed this is an
opportunity and so I'm going to be very
disciplined very intentional to do what
George has said here to get all of your
ducks in a row and then investing wisely
but also saying this is how this is
going to change our life this money is
going to change our life for the better
and we're going to plan every dollar of
it exactly and uh you know you you
mentioned that you're of the Jewish
faith and there's a lot that that has to
say about money and your Rabbi can walk
you through what that looks like but
there's still that element of I'm a
steward of this money it was entrusted
to me I want to make the most of it and
what that means is having a long-term
mindset so it's not what we're gonna do
with this money in the next year it's
what is this going to do for us 20 years
from now I want to leave an inheritance
to my grandchildren's grandchildren yeah
that's a very different mindset and then
you you make different decisions when
you use that as a filter and so when you
invest this money let's say you put a
big chunk in a taxable brokerage account
outside of retirement and just let it
grow well hopefully that says I'm not
touching that money
I want to let that money grow then you
take a certain portion you say all right
we're going to spend this much we're
going to go on one really fun trip as a
legacy uh to to mom who left this to us
and that's going to be our spending
money and then the rest we're going to
go you know we're going to give 10
percent and we're going to upgrade the
car and you start to do these reasonable
things over a slow longer period of time
with a lot of trustworthy Pros in your
corner and then you look up 20 years
from now and that money grew and you
feel really good about the
intentionality you had with it
okay now the other question I have is
um and I just I don't know how to put it
out with their searches one in my head
and yet
my husband
um this morning has been with law and he
also found out that his last day of work
um is going to be the day before
Thanksgiving okay um do I um if this if
the actual channel the high school is
through
um and they actually do do the cash on
for doing important additional
um couple months aside since we already
know yeah laid off absolutely put it put
a chunk of money aside to get you
through that period and then let's get
him back to work if that's the plan ASAP
but that's the wise thing to do thanks
so much for the call this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life your
money your work all of it I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by Ken Coleman
some have called us the root beer float
of radio that's right it's happening
more often by the way people are coming
up to us at our live events in
Minneapolis and Sacramento the last two
weeks and they're offering their opinion
on who's who is the vanilla ice cream
beer and who's the vanilla ice cream and
George said on the air this is by the
way if you have no idea what we're
talking about we had a nice podcast
review and the guy said something along
those lines that we reminded him of a
root beer float or something and so I
said well which one do you think you are
and you said you think you're the root
beer yeah well you're just so smooth
well so cool well the people in the
audience are voting so they think that
George is the vanilla wow and then I'm
the root beer that hurts boy this is why
they're very passionate
thank you for the votes out there uh
either way people are now commenting in
the uh the the picture lines what they
think I love it and you know Ken we're
not the heroes that America needs but
we're the ones it deserves right now and
I don't even know where he was going
with it you never know yeah yeah so
we're taking your calls we're happy to
be your dessert beverage here on this
lovely Friday and all it takes is a free
phone call to the number triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life your
work your money how it all intersects
and Josh has decided to do that out in
Buffalo New York to kick us off Josh
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey guys thank you for having me
absolutely what's going on
yeah so Ken I gotta say I think you're
the ice cream yeah but I'll just leave
that there all right I'm not gonna argue
the people have spoken and uh so there
it is I'm not gonna argue with a member
of the bills Mafia that that's dangerous
you know oh boy yeah be careful I know
all right thank you so all right guys
I'm feeling uh stagnant in my career
uh and I just really don't know
what my next best step is okay so what
are the steps in front of you because
when somebody says I don't know what my
next best step is that implies to me
that you've got some steps in front of
you you're just not quite sure where to
go is that true
um yeah yeah I think I would say so so
what give me the steps what are we
considering
yeah so
um
um a Year's worth of education and it's
in biblical studies
um so there's a a big part of me that
really desires to be in Ministry
full-time
um and then there's another part of me
um that just with some of my attitudes
and skills uh wants to be in Salesforce
yeah I'm not doing either of those
things currently and I kind of don't
know what's best to decide I don't know
what's most true to where I am now and
where to go from here yeah okay so
there's a little simple test when
somebody presents to me a couple of
options when I'm coaching them and I
think you've got to get your head and
heart aligned and whenever I hear
something like this it's usually a case
of a wrestling match between The Head
and the Heart and I think your heart's
telling you one thing I think your
head's telling you the other is that
true
yeah I guess I would say so because
which one you know which one Give me the
give me the corners we got we got two
opposers who's in the blue corner and
who's in the Red Corner so let's go
heart what's your heart saying which one
my heart uh is you know I desire to be a
pastor and being in full-time Ministry
okay and your head's telling you sales
because it's a Better Living better
benefits yada yada yada right
yeah I would uh I would say so okay so
how long would it take for you to get
qualified to be a full-time Pastor
what's left on that Journey if we said
today and we're not saying that but if
we said we're going to choose to pursue
the heart which I always think you
should
how long would it take you to get there
what's that what's the time and the cost
but I would say it might
you know three or four years three or
four years and how much money
Maybe
20 000. okay I don't quite know that's
good I want you to go from maybe to
certain all right so there's four
qualifying questions I wrote about
George in the book from paycheck to
purpose because getting qualified is
very intimidating Josh is an example so
Josh the first question is what do I
need to learn that's the education piece
the second question is what do I need to
do that's the experience piece the third
question is what is it going to cost me
that's the economic piece and then how
long will all of this take based on my
financial reality that's the expectation
question so if you're right and I want
you to go back and examine this let's
find out how much it's really going to
cost for you to get the education
required to get hired now listen in the
ministry you don't have to have a
masters in Divinity that but a church
may require a theology you need to do
your homework and say what is absolutely
required for me to be in full-time
ministry as a pastor and then how much
is that going to cost me and based on my
financial reality how long will that
take that's your homework assignment now
Josh I want to get your head and heart
aligned because I'm going to suggest to
you
now I'll bet you're really good in sales
you better be if you're going to try to
sell people into going to heaven right
yeah so here's the deal yeah probably
wouldn't hurt for you to go get a
full-time sales job and sell something
that you can get excited about and guess
what that's going to do that's going to
get you the money you need and you go
part-time and you're selling and then
you're getting the degree or whatever
experience is necessary to get that
full-time Ministry job but I think it's
a combination and I think it's the sales
job that's going to get you in a
position to step into Ministry that's
what I think
question about that
I mean no I it's honestly getting me
kind of stirred up just thinking about
it as far as order of operations I felt
at a standstill and yeah it's giving me
pretty fast from stagnant to stirred
there's your new book Ken there it is I
just blew the foam off the top of the
root beer float right there there it is
I was excited well I I think that really
is the answer Josh you need to commit
today
to trust God and the calling on your
life and go do it
you step out he steps in little theology
for you and I think in the meantime you
go get a good sales job and let's go
make some money that's going to take
care put you in a place to step into
that full-time Ministry role really
stable
Josh has just dumbfounded he could not
speak he's speechless
you know what I'm trying to send Josh a
copy of your book from paycheck to
perfect thank you George to equip him uh
to add another E to all the E's you just
dropped when we want to equip him you
like that hey you know what I do want to
do this really quick because people
listen to a lot of people listening to
watching the show right now and you know
what you want to do but you're not doing
it because you're absolutely terrified
on what that next step is so I want to
get you unstuck they're called the four
qualifying questions okay here it is the
education question what do I need to
learn it does not necessarily mean a
diploma but it's some level of
qualification what do I need to learn
that's the education question number two
the experience question what do I need
to do some people try to step up high on
the ladder when they got to step here on
the lowest rung third question the
economic question what is this this this
education and experience gonna cost me
and then third now that I can look at
the real money I go wait a second based
on my financial realities how long will
those first three steps take that's the
expectation question here's what happens
with those four questions George we come
up with clear answers and a very clearly
defined plan guess what it's not so
scary when I could see the path forward
well you've said Clarity breeds
confidence that's exactly what we just
did for Josh and I love it awesome call
all right we're excited for you Josh
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and a full affordable way
to make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back America to the Ramsey Show
I'm George Campbell host of the entree
leadership podcast the fine print
podcast and co-host of the smart money
Happy Hour podcast one of our newest
shows from the Ramsey Network that I
co-host with our friend Rachel Cruz and
I'm joined this hour by our friend Ken
Coleman host of the Ken Coleman show you
can find all of those shows on the
Ramsey Network or wherever you listen to
podcasts and by the way folks if you
like this show that you're listening to
right now the Ramsay show please
consider subscribing and leaving us a
review and sharing it with friends that
is how this show grows it's by word of
mouth it's by people like you that hey
you got to check out this podcast it's
really inspired me on my money Journey
on my work Journey my relationship
journey and we so so appreciate we've
got an influx of reviews and five star
reviews that have been coming in and
it's because of you all so thank you so
much for listening I should point out
that that if you've stumbled across us
or you just love Dave so much that you
hate us uh don't leave that review
because I won't read a George might but
I won't yeah no thanks George Goes Down
the dark Rabbit Hole of neurosis uh I on
the other hand could care less I tell
people all the time they can call me if
I say something you don't like fantastic
I want you to feel free to voice it just
know I'm not reading it it's gonna it's
gonna be lost in the abyss Life's too
short I agree I really I do agree with
that and the old adage goes if you've
got nothing nice to say don't say it at
all there it is thanks to the internet
now the comment section keyboard
Warriors has become a lot of Courage
when you don't have to look somebody in
the eye and say it agreed fascinating
social media although you and I are
little guys we're probably nobody's
afraid to say anything to us that's fine
we can handle it we can handle it we got
thick skin well we really don't speaking
of social media Ken there's so many
videos out there oh I got a video for it
well people keep sending them to us and
hey you guys gotta react to this and so
there was one that went viral oh and you
reacted to it on the Ken Coleman show I
did and I told James I said James I want
to bring it over here and I want you to
react to this as well I've already seen
this all right now let me set this up
very briefly and we're going to pause it
a few times so so stay with us this is a
very popular and viral Tick Tock and and
this is a real sentiment
I want you to understand something we're
not about to show you this and Destroy
and criticize and belittle the sentiment
we will take issue with some things
factually but understand and I want to
set this up properly there are millions
and millions of Americans George Who
feel the way that this gentleman feels
so you take this with a Shaker of salt
and understand this is why we do what we
do here at Ramsey Solutions let's roll
the video
if you're making less than 25 an hour
right now you should be terrified if you
are making less than 25 you're going to
be very pissed off by the time we get to
the end of this video all right Paul's
information here is going to scare this
all right pause first of all okay what
he just said there is not true you'll be
fine if you're making 25 an hour we
don't go viral on Tick Tock without some
fear-mongering Ken boys scare the whoop
out of you he said you're not gonna
sleep tonight if you make less than 25
bucks an hour okay this is absolute
nonsense but a lot of people feel this
way all right now George will tell you
how we can do this later let's keep
going
I just spent some time looking at some
monthly averages of regular cost of
living all across the U.S average costs
and I put them all in a spreadsheet and
did all the math for you so you can see
exactly what this big picture is here so
these are just normal expenses that most
single consumers have and this is all of
them laid out national average right
here the average cost of an apartment is
16.59 a month where groceries are going
to spend 500 bucks on that and you go
down a list here but add all that up
you're looking at 32.85 a month just in
your cost of living expenses which means
to break even pause now George I'm gonna
let you step in here but I've pointed
this out on my show we're already uh
we're already a little bit out of whack
here uh when you look at just the the
average vehicle payment the average used
car payment is just a shade under 700 a
month insane so so we're not even
working with real numbers here all right
and and and and then let's just point
out that what if you didn't have that
car payment how far would that go one
thousand percent well one of the reasons
people don't have margin is because they
are living with payments giving all of
their hard-earned money to lenders every
month and they think well this is the
path this is how I get Financial Freedom
this is what success looks like but we
teach no debt pay for things with cash
get reasonable used cars and so this is
a big part of the picture of why there's
no margin in this person's budget that's
right and that's why I pointed this out
America he's saying you can't make
enough this whole video is if you should
be making way more than 25 dollars an
hour which by the way I'm for that
that's what I spent a lot of my time
doing helping people make really good
money but to say that you're the man is
keeping you down when we don't even have
the car payment correctly put in this
budget and people think that that's just
something they've got to carry around so
all right let's keep rolling and just
squeeze by paycheck to paycheck you have
to be making 32.85 every four weeks so
this is calculated at your monthly
income at a 40 hour work week so it's
your hourly rate times 160 hours for
four weeks in a month so I don't believe
anybody should have to work more than a
40 hour week just to survive now this
tax column represents how much you'd be
paying each month in taxes after you add
up all your withholdings I figured this
out by looking at my pay stubs from the
last time I was an employee about six
years ago so you got your gross income
you got your net income after you pay
this tax which would go in this column
and fill it all in the first time you
see a number higher than this number is
at 25 an hour it could even get worse
than that because chances are you're
gonna be paying more than 16 in total
withholdings and anything like child
support or alimony to that and forget
about it so this leaves you with very
limited options you either have to kill
yourself working way way too many hours
or you've got to figure out a way to
make a ton of money pause so there's two
options Ken all right George that's what
I wanted you to weigh in on that because
I I wait on this on my show but this is
a false Choice kill yourself most people
lose hope because they back themselves
into a corner and decide there's only
two choices Ken either kill myself
working jobs I I hate or uh that's it
that's it this is the only path yeah so
you looked at the spreadsheet and
nothing there's no advice in this Tick
Tock about controlling spending no so
what issues do you have if you're just
listening you're not seeing the
spreadsheet but outlined here the first
number is rent at 1659 which he claims
is the average rent uh in the US I don't
buy that now if you're on the coast
you're in some higher cost of living
cities yes but let me tell you Ken if
this is based on a single person let's
say a single young guy right that's kind
of who he's talking to in this video
well I was not living by myself in a
nice apartment when I was a single young
guy in my entry-level job I had a
roommate he might have multiple
roommates and so to be paying 1659 is
insane I would say well time to get a
roommate that cuts your rent down to
8.25 and it just gave you 800 in margin
back in your life
now let's pay off that car because
you're paying 400 bucks a month towards
that car payment or you sell the car
that's an extra 400 back in our life now
look what happens Ken we have an extra
twelve hundred dollars of margin that we
can breathe don't forget the streaming
he's got 37 down for streaming
yes yes and so there are ways to trim
the budget the question are what are you
what are you willing to do because don't
tell me you can't don't tell me you
can't get a roommate say you're
unwilling to get a roommate and this is
for a short period of time we're
sacrificing number one Ken would say
well we can help you get your income up
that's right if you don't have enough to
make ends meet because of your cost of
living
and by the way forty thousand dollars
can go a long way in Idaho and it may
not go a long way in L.A and there's the
other part of the narrative so the one
is kill yourself working crazy amounts
of hours or go have to make more money
like that's a bad thing if the way it's
positioned is like oh get a job where
you make more money like have to bust it
I can't quiet quit right I got I got
instead of quiet quitting how about some
uh gritty greatness George oh how about
that that's a new one I know what he's
talking about that well can we know this
and we're confident about it because we
meet people every day Main Street folks
who come to our debt free stage and
guess what for a short period of time
they worked extra they worked more than
40 hours a week they work 60 hours a
week because they wanted to sacrifice
for a short time instead of being in
pain for a long time which is where most
of America finds themselves living in
mediocrity for 20 years because they
don't want to sacrifice for two which by
the way is the average amount of time it
takes for our folks to get out of debt
I'm gonna tell you where this kind of
this kind and again a lot of people feel
this I get it but when it's positioned
as though you are a victim and this
video whether meant to be made this way
or not is all about making the person
who watched this video feel like a
victim
as opposed to saying wait a second you
don't have to accept this
this isn't some sentence this may be a
season of your life but it's not a life
sentence the hamster wheel is not your
miserable plot that somebody more
powerful than you has bestowed upon you
yeah
believing that it can be different and
then
actions that lead you towards Freedom
long term and that's exactly what we do
we have a solution we're not just trying
to rile you up about the problem we want
to show you a way out show you hope
instead of these hope Stealers out there
telling you it's everyone else's problem
and you're not the solution this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today day that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right folks the few holidays going
on today one is Veterans Day which is uh
way more important than this other one
that is totally made up which is singles
day that's right it is also I know Ken
wait a second are you for real this is a
real thing singles day as in people who
are not married exactly oh my and we
want to make sure they are seen today
and it's not just the day to celebrate
that's probably a good idea there's a
reason they're not married they're not
being seen enough well here's the good
news Ken we love any excuse to give
folks a great deal for Christmas so we
decided let's throw a singles day one
day sale today only the Ramsey singles
Day Sale is happening at
ramsaysolutions.com and so today only
single or not
you can find the best prices on gifts
for everyone this one day sale truly has
some great deals there like our friend
Ken Coleman right next to me is increase
your income bundle it's got everything
you need to get a better paycheck and
find the work you were born to do get
yourself a spouse
that's a kind of an indirect play there
that's a way to increase the income dual
income yeah that's it that's it well the
bundle's normally 40 bucks today we put
it on sale for just 24 bucks we also
have our friend Dr John deloney's
best-selling audiobook redefining
anxiety for just seven bucks wow you can
also gift your loved ones the number one
plan Millions have used to pay off debt
with a Total Money Makeover bundle which
is just 25 bucks and now these singles
day uh deals aren't just for grown-ups
Ken we included the kids here so forget
about the toys uh that break and give
the kids a lifetime of Hope with our
adventure pack and these deals are again
just for today only for singles day shop
all of the gifts and more at
ramseysolutions.com I you know George
I've been I've been married more than
I've been single my one year I got
married at 23 and I've been married 24
almost 25 years congratulations and I
don't understand why so many people are
afraid to commit and get married agree
uh just go look at the data I'm just
gonna drop this here since it's singles
day all right and we're giving all the
these deals how about some wisdom oh all
right uh
your health your mental health uh income
everything everything goes up when
you're married it's a better quality of
life that's all I'm going to say go look
it up I'm not making it up it's a good
word yeah from from Pastor Ken thank you
and let's not let's think I mean
honestly what's what's tomorrow National
pretzel day wow we've got too many days
I know we got too many celebrations
let's scale it down yeah it's it's a bit
much well Ken we are doing something fun
today we decided earlier on the show
yeah we're gonna try something out we're
going to go live on Instagram at Ken
Coleman from his feed while we are on
the Ramsey Show and we're going to take
your questions from the Instagram live
feed and here's the scariest part
America Ken is running it from his phone
by himself all right George acts like I
can't operate I've done Instagram lives
many times and I'm going to be right
here taking your money and work
questions Zach the social media Guru is
in the control room
down this is like Evil Knievel having
the ambulance nearby no stop it worst
case and I'll hand the phone to George
and and we'll work it together we're
going to take your questions just from
Instagram for one entire segment that's
next segment so you got to go to Atkin
Coleman and if you haven't followed me
do yourself a favor wow okay and follow
me and then jump in and send your
questions so 2 45 Central time we're
going live jump on there Ken's Instagram
and we're gonna take your questions so
ask good ones I don't just fill up the
feed with with gibberish I'm not going
to take any silly questions I'm not uh
who's the guy in Anchorman that says
anything he sees Ron Burgundy yeah I'm
not Ron Burgundy so it's a no silliness
all right only real questions I love it
well that'll be fun stay class here well
in the meantime let's get to some calls
Andrea's on the line in Omaha Nebraska
Andrea welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call this
afternoon absolutely what's going on
okay so I have a question
um we are a family of seven and we are
in babysit I step two we started three
years ago we've paid off 168 000. and we
have 220 yeah that's incredible
celebrate that
um we have 228 still to go thousand
um and so it's a marathon for us
so my question is
um what's a reasonable amount for an
emergency fund for our family for the
size of our family and we have like a
furnace that's 28 years old and how do
we
save for that I know I was thinking fun
but how much would be okay to take from
like our rollover to put towards a
sinking fund and baby stuff too
great question well as you know baby
step one thousand dollar starter
emergency fund and what you're saying is
hey we are in this thing for a long time
and we got a big family with a lot of
expenses do we get a do we get a pass
does it change for us is that the
question
well uh yeah I'm just not comfortable
like so right now our emergency fund is
8 000.
um because that was what I was
comfortable with
um just having anything come up and then
now uh we've gotten a couple ideas of
what a new furnace would cost and that'd
be like 10 to 12 even fifteen thousand
wow and I would be worried that if that
happened we would completely wipe out
our emergency fund so we'll agreed as
you head into winter Nebraska that
scares me
yes yeah exactly so I'm trying to figure
out the balance I guess yeah well the
sinking fund is correct and if you know
it's not a surprise when this furnace
goes out you mentioned it's 28 years old
and so it's okay to pause the baby steps
to save up to cash flow this new furnace
and it's also fine if you want to do the
sinking fund and lean towards you know
funding this furnace for a season that's
not forever you're going to be done with
that pretty soon right
okay yeah well that's I guess my
question because it's really hard for me
to pause on our rollover because we've
made so much progress so I guess that
was part of it I my husband's like it's
okay if we pause it and I go like no no
we gotta keep going keep moving forward
it feels like a setback but you guys you
know you you have a mountain here this
is not something where you're like all
right we're gonna knock this out in 18
months uh now I hope you have an amazing
income because of the 400 000 in debt
can you tell me what it is
yeah so um originally it was student
loans um car payments and then like two
home good credit cards um but now it we
have just
um got it down to my husband's student
loans which um so those are medical
school loans okay I was gonna say I was
like I hope there's a doctor in the
house
yes there is that level of debt how big
is the uh how big is the house
square feet about 2500 square feet all
right I'm just going to tell you I grew
up my my dad took pinching pennies to
another level could have been an
Olympian at it uh we had kerosene
heaters things like that so and
depending on the size of the house if
you needed a true backup plan if you
didn't have this the the the sinking
fund ready yeah I'd have a backup plan
for that too wow yeah that's not a
that's not a bad call do you understand
what I'm saying like I'm just saying if
this thing goes in in the middle winter
you know how could you heat your house
would you get by for a few weeks could
you get by for even a month I'm just
saying I'm saying keep funding it but
you might be surprised you know
depending on where you live and it's not
a huge house so I don't know what your
living's like in there but I I'm always
trying to give something like true
emergency backup not just the money yes
but here's what I don't like about you
know well we have a bigger emergency
fund because it's more comfortable the
problem is comfort is what leads us into
debt in the first place and so I like
the discomfort I like the fear that
stoked me go oh my gosh we are not it's
true because the truth is you're not
safe when you owe someone four hundred
thousand dollars and you guys know that
it's the reason you got a hold of this
plan and you've been doing it it and so
I'd encourage you not to have this big
cushion to fall back on because then you
go well we can get by we can scale back
the debt payoff a little bit that's a
good point and truthfully with your
income if something happened you could
pause and cash flow within a month or
two
yeah you guys are making and we haven't
touched that emergency fund
um and so that has been strictly I think
I just have a fear of one of the kids
and going to the hospital and then there
it is that's you know even though you're
not required a lot so you could get on a
payment plan and you could pay it off
really quickly
so that I don't want that either oh I
understand I know but but I'm walking
you through the worst case scenario yeah
I I yeah can I just okay I'm gonna hit
you with real life here Andrea so Stacy
and I same deal large emergency fund we
had it fully funded and uh both of my
boys play football both
had surgery
both this season yeah they're naming a
hallway after us over at the uh Bone and
Joint Institute okay uh you know but
we've been able to cash flow it we
didn't have to emergency fund didn't
have to get touched that's my point yes
you understand Andrea like the emergency
fund is for a full-blown emergency
having to pay for a surgery or some
medical thing like that with your income
you can cash for that and we know the
furnace is on its way out let's go ahead
and just fund it replace it you seven
thousand of the 8 000 and use that
towards the furnace and you guys are
gonna be debt free
um in no time with this kind of
intensity and you can always pause it
and I know it's not fun but you will get
there just don't get too comfortable so
thank you so much for the call we are
cheering you guys on
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show as we
mentioned in our previous segment we are
going live and we are live right now on
Ken Coleman's Instagram feed on top of
being live on the Ramsey Show it's like
rubbing my belly and trying to tap my
head at the same time it's very
confusing I never did that well but we
promised the folks on Instagram and we'd
answer a few of their questions and so
that's what you guys get to hear on the
Ramsay show and uh Ken we got a great
one already yeah the lovely B is the
first question we're going to read I got
offered a new job that's more pay should
I take it I love the job I have now
but it's ten dollars more an hour oh now
this is the wrestling match right do I
take more money George the brain is
always going to go take more money but
her heart's going I love where I am and
this is a legit wrestling match here so
here is the answer lovely B you better
write down why you love your current job
why do you love that current job let's
get real specific about it and then
let's look at this new job offer and say
is there anything about this new job
offer that pays me ten dollars more an
hour that is similar and can I get to a
oh I could love this new job if the
answer is no
I'd probably pass on the ten dollars
more an hour so there you go that's good
wisdom I got another one here from Joe
Oklahoma State Joe Oklahoma is his name
is it the wrong time to buy a house
right now and that's a great question
can a lot of people are freaking out
they're trying to time this housing
market which is so unpredictable and the
truth is there's never a wrong time to
buy the house if you can financially
afford the house and what we mean by
that is a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
with a payment that's no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay and by the
way interest rates are high I know that
but guess what you can refinance when
interest rates go back down and so
that's not the end of the world I know
it's not fun to have that extra on your
payment but if you can still withstand
it with that 25 threshold then yes it's
a great time to buy a house it's a great
time all right here's another one
pragland 64 says guys talk about the
court the Texas judge halting the loan
forgiveness this is big news not much to
talk about except to say I told you so
my audience knows this it's
unconstitutional look it up we learned
about this in the fifth or sixth grade
folks this is not political it's just
the Constitution I love that Ken is like
Google the Constitution bro that's his
advice well you know he doesn't have the
authority to do it and we knew it was
going to be challenged so that's why we
tell you to pay off your loans all right
another one George let's see here
[Music]
uh
can you explain how to win with LinkedIn
interesting George now you were social
media specialist before you became a
Ramsay personality give us 30 seconds on
how to win with LinkedIn number one it's
not just to throw things at people and
just always be posting you need to
engage you need to jump into other
people's conversations be commenting be
messaging really try to connect this is
not the time to do your cold sales pitch
this is the time to actually be a person
and the more you do that the more you
will win on top of posting quality
content on there your insights your
experience that's what people want to
see all right uh let's see Demona roll
if I'm saying that right what's more
important 401k or 529 oh well they're I
have to pay them as separate we that's
baby step four and five you should be
doing both start with 15 of your income
into retirement into the 401K then you
can move to the 529 and put as much as
you can into there by the way if you're
joining the Ramsay show right now you've
popped in George Campbell and I are
answering questions live from Instagram
viewers at Ken Coleman uh if you head on
over there we're doing just Instagram
live questions here's jaradina80 love
the random usernames it always tickles
me uh how to become more confident in
your life and work one simple answer I
believe that the key to confidence is
Clarity I don't care what area of your
life it is
confidence comes when we're clear but
when we're not clear and otherwise in
other words we're doubtful
that's very natural to not have
confidence so if it's confidence in
money confidence in your relationships
confidence in your work get clear get to
the bottom of where the Doubt's coming
from and then address that you're going
to be confident that's good I got one
from Ambit media when should we downsize
our home to be debt free sooner this is
a great question it is not the right
path for everyone and truthfully a lot
of people use it as a shortcut can
because they don't want to do the hard
work and it feels like they can LeapFrog
and for some people it does make sense
but if you can be debt free within two
years without selling the home don't
sell the home because it's a headache
and there's a lot of fees involved and
you got to turn around and then buy
another home and so don't do it unless
it's a drastic situation and you already
have way too much house and the
payment's killing you and it will help
you become debt free that much sooner so
George watch out now we're gonna get
this is gonna get oh boy potentially
controversial this is from NG squinchy
which by the way is that the
controversial part no it might be
depending on how you get offended these
days days uh but it is uh it is uh the
username hi Ken my boyfriend of 11
months is not on board with the Ramsay
ways or the baby steps I love him so
much
and I'm terrified to break it off please
advise me as if I was your daughter wow
can you hear that she's squinchy I am
now officially the old man of the Ramsey
Show and here's what I would tell you if
you were Josie my daughter
you're giving me ultimatum and you
explain why
if we're going to go to the next level
in our relationship we have got to be on
the same page about money or else why
are we dating I'm not doing this just to
have a buddy or a pal and so I would
give him the ultimatum to say this is
what I believe about money and if you
don't believe that way I totally get it
but you and I aren't right for each
other and I would say I'm out
George Ken this is a hot one I gotta
jump in on Hollis Robinson said I'm
afraid to choose a career I want to make
sure God approves of the career
well you know I don't like that what is
the heart behind that well I think it
comes from a good place but uh God
doesn't uh give us the stamp of approval
that I think we expect him to what he
does is give us judgment he gives us
discernment gave us a heart and I can
tell you if you use what I teach and
this job allows you to use what you do
best that's talent that God gave you it
allows you to do something you love
that's the heart that God gave you and
it allows you to create results that
matter to you again that's that's the
discernment that God gave you that is
the approval go for it uh let's just
answer a funnel one here Ken from Jeff
by the way if you just jumped in George
and I are answering questions on
Instagram live at Ken Coleman if you
want to jump in if you're confused by
the manic spree that we're on Instagram
these are fast and furious uh is it true
from Jeff Bush photo video that George
had a real life camel at his wedding and
yes that is 100 absolutely true I can
confirm this and it's not fake news the
22nd story is we won a free low local
Wedding Contest a twenty eight thousand
dollar wedding package and so I thought
I'm gonna spring 700 bucks to get a guy
to bring a camel to this wedding as a
photo op just to be silly and fun George
I got a phone one for you red sewing
says best way to save for college is a
high schooler who has a small business
oh that's incredible well number one
live on as little as you can make and
throw as much as you can into savings uh
you don't have a ton of time so I would
not put it in the stock market but a
high yield savings account is a great
place to store that money as you
continue to work and scholarships make
sure you're applying for scholarships as
an extra part-time job yeah Sean
perriello says how do you stay motivated
at a job that won't train someone for
two years Sally triples after the
training I'd say Sean do you want to be
there long term forget the two years in
the tripling of the salary do you want
to be there long term if you do
patience it's a beautiful thing wait
crush the now you'll get the next
anything worth doing or getting is worth
waiting here's one from Ben Wilson how
do you get out of debt when you have two
full-time jobs and nothing to cut back
on wow well if you don't have any
margins to throw at the debt with two
full-time jobs you're not getting paid
enough at either of them so Ken would
say you got to get better jobs that's it
better paycheck uh this is fun this is
again oh see you already mentioned this
guys but I think this is fun he may be
in the lobby would you rather fight a
one
horse-sized duck or a six duck-sized
horse oh this is a classic conundrum Ken
uh I I gotta tell you I'm going with the
smaller yeah the duck size smaller of
the two I can take them boy there you go
there's my Ron Burgundy moment uh let's
see uh Ken what are the dangers of
remote work what would scare you away I
think two things number one not having
the relationship that you get and from
collaboration and being around
co-workers and feeling lonely that could
be a danger of remote work in the second
out of sight out of mind if your leader
doesn't see you hear you and it gets to
a layoff situation you could be the
first one on the Block that is a danger
well we are running out of time I gotta
say this has been so fun going on
Instagram live answering questions live
on the Ramsay Show Instagram myself be
sure to follow us at Ken Coleman at
George Campbell with a K we love helping
people over on social media yeah thank
you for all of that good times good hour
Ken appreciate you uh that puts this
hour of the Ramsay show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it don't go anywhere more of the Ramsey
show will be coming your way
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your life I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell joined by my colleague Ken
Coleman this hour and we are taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five I would love to help
you with any money questions Crossroads
you're facing your life and Ken is uh
he's the man when it comes to your work
your purpose your career how to navigate
all of those challenges and we are both
here to talk about the intersection of
all of that so triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call and Kyle kicks us off in my
hometown the great city of Boston
Massachusetts Kyle welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call how you
doing
good um so I have less of a numbers
questioning more of a philosophical
question
um so just for some background
um I'm 24 years old I've been working
for the federal government since I was
18.
um so on paper
um my job is amazing you know great
retirement great benefits I made great
money for my age
um but ever since covid happened
um we're fully remote now
um and you know in terms of my mental
health I think things have deteriorated
a little bit and I guess ultimately
before I keep on blabbering my question
is is it bad that the only fulfillment
my job is giving me is a paycheck yeah
it is that's why I wrote my last book
from paycheck to purpose because if we
look at work and experience work as just
a thing that we do for provision
slowly our soul seeps out of our body
I don't apologize for saying this I
believe that we were created to
contribute through our work I was just
reading something today on the plane
back from Minneapolis
that a professor out of the University
of California
did 20 years of research studying people
um and they found that the good stress
meaning the stress from a challenge a
challenge is something that we we it
pushes us we're able to do it but it
pushes us and it rewards us when we meet
that challenge and work that the longer
we do that the longer we live that we're
healthier so there I mean this is the
way that the the human body and the Soul
we are spirits
uh this is the way we're wired and so
absolutely and it's already happening to
you you're 24 years of age
and and your soul is slowly seeping out
of your body and if you just think about
the average American Kyle spins and
you're on the front end of this 90 000
Plus hours at work in their lifetime
Monday through Friday and you go in and
you have no fulfillment what's going to
happen is
and and it's more intense for for for
some people than others
but the undercurrent begins to go wait a
second my work doesn't matter to me
and then we start to say do I matter
and now that can get really intense
you're starting to feel that yeah
yeah and just you know it's just hard
because
um you know I have a great boss but um
the work just isn't challenging but then
I think you know
um I'm already making eighty thousand
dollars and I basically have a ladder
that'll take me up to 150 000 so then I
think
um you know well even if my job isn't
giving me fulfillment maybe I can devote
every other hour of the day to doing
things that fulfill my time but like you
said I mean that 90 000 hour number is
pretty staggering you know yeah well so
you make a very good point and I'm glad
you brought this up so you could choose
that path
to say I'm going to stay in this path
and I'm going to eventually get up the
ladder and make 150 000 have all this
government you know uh retirement
accounts and all these things and then
I'm going to find fulfillment you know
in volunteering at nights and weekends
you could choose that and I'm not going
to say that that is wrong I don't think
this is a right or wrong but I would
challenge you that that is a less than
choice you could leave the government
sector and go to the private sector and
make as much and completely more
and actually do something that fulfills
you
you know we we've got the I think part
of it part of it's definitely
complacency too you know no I've just
been just wondering no I'm gonna tell
you complacency is the output I'm gonna
tell you what's going on and this is not
judging you I'm just trying to help you
it's not complacency it's Comfort you've
gotten comfortable with what you know
and even though you're even though
you're miserable you're going well at
least I know what to expect and we
humans would rather be miserable than
uncomfortable
but Life Starts at the end of our
comfort zone somebody said I saw it on a
t-shirt or a coffee mug one time I'm
sorry I don't know who to attribute that
to it's not mine but it's true
and so I would tell you Kyle I'm going
to give you my get clear assessment
which is going to measure your talent
what you do best your passion work you
love and then your mission results that
motivate you when you all three of those
things come together it looks like this
you're using what you do best to do what
you love to produce results that matter
to you let me tell you what's happening
you're on fire you can't burn out that
flame cannot be extinguished because you
are doing what your creator puts you on
this planet to do and I'm going to give
you that get clear assessment because my
challenge to you is not just to take the
assessment but to look at that purpose
statement and the detailed report you're
going to get on all three of those areas
and let that become a high level job
description and then because you've got
good experience and you've got skill
let's make the transition we don't have
to rush you're in no dire situation you
love your boss all that's good but now
is the time at 24 to choose the path
of purpose and it is going to be
uncomfortable but I can tell you this
Kyle when you get to the end of your
journey and I hope you make it to a long
life and an old age I'd rather you look
back and reminisce
not regret and that's the choice we as
humans have to choose and Ken there
seems to be a four buckets or so where
someone either they don't get paid
enough but they love what they do they
get paid really well like Kyle but they
hate what they do then there's the I I
don't get paid enough and I hate what I
do right and then there's the Sweet Spot
which is what you're talking about you
can get paid really well and love what
you do yeah or here's another thing you
can love what you do and it's enough
money
the third largest group of net worth
millionaires are teachers with a median
salary a median of sixty thousand
dollars you know I'm all for people
making as much money as you want but I
can tell you this uh
meaning is what I define success by not
money well there's been so many studies
that show after a certain dollar amount
you don't actually increase happiness
and joy the income number seventy five
thousand dollars is pretty interesting
so people think well if I just made 80
can my life would no you go with you and
so an increased income lifestyle creep
happens you just spend more and you go
well that wasn't it either I don't have
the joy in my life I don't have the
passion that's exactly right I mean
here's the deal when it's all said and
done and we want you to have Financial
Peace and that's what we're about here
on the Ramsey show but when it's all
said and done all of that financial
piece is going to allow you to make the
contribution you want to make anyway and
so let's be let's begin to look at work
as more than just
provision let's look at as an
opportunity for contribution and it
reminds me of this quote I think it was
from Rachel Cruz she said contentment
turns what we have into enough yeah
great man there is such a lack of
contentment in today's culture because
of all the marketing and everything's 24
7 and all the inputs we have uh it says
you're not enough you don't have enough
you need to be doing more you need to be
more and man that is an endless Chase
so we gotta stop and go enough is enough
we're gonna learn to be content and if
we're not content with where we are
we're going to be driven to get to that
next thing but man if you keep chasing
you'll never get there yeah it's true so
run your own race if you want to change
careers you have the ability to do that
in this country there's so much
opportunity out there but please don't
stay Paralyzed by indecision don't do
that that is the worst place to be take
action in your life you have control
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Ramsey personality George Campbell
joined by Ken Coleman this hour and
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Jonathan joins us up next in Vancouver
Washington Jonathan welcome to the show
all right guys thanks for having me
absolutely how can we help today
yeah so I am currently a 19 year old
full-time working full-time college
student
um I actually just recently I just
bought a car in March of this year and I
don't pay a dime for college because I
worked at FedEx and FedEx pays for all
my college
I've been working since I was about 16
years old
um and I have had a little bit of a
spending issue uh and I only have about
two thousand dollars in my savings
account so I was wondering if you guys
could give me some ways to budget my
money better and just say you know my
friends asked me to go out say no and
have that uh that um what's the word I'm
looking for
discipline yes yes yeah so George is a
money guy let George work on the old
budget for you I'm curious what are you
spending the money on do you think you
know like what are your major areas of
expenditure yeah so I actually
refinanced my car I was paying an arm
and a leg a month about 400 a month just
for the car payment alone and another
270 just for my insurance
um so I just refinanced the car and a
lot of it was going to my bills I'm very
independent I'm on my own phone plan I
pay for my own gas my own groceries a
lot of things
um I just the stuff that I do save and
I'm I have quite a bit left over at the
end of the month I just spend on impulse
decisions uh like impulse buys
okay so Jonathan what are you making
right now
if I make 22.90 an hour and about 40 000
a year wow while being in school full
time yes when do you graduate
all right I'm planning on graduating
2026. okay so you just started yes sir
and what career field are you looking to
get into law enforcement okay so you
have two grand you've been working for
three years now you're a young guy and
you said you paid cash for this car so
you don't have the car payment anymore
no I actually do have the car payment
explain that you said you paid cash for
the car
oh no I did not pay cash I put a three
thousand dollars down okay that's very
different what's the car worth
uh it's worth about 20 000 right now
okay and what is left on the loan
uh about twenty three thousand yes okay
I mean it's a lot of car for your income
we we say we don't want all the things
with the motors in it to add up to more
than half of your annual income and you
are right there yeah uh for a 19 year
old to be driving a car that nice uh so
let's just say you keep the car what is
the plan to pay this thing off
uh just keep on my payments um I like I
said I refinanced this my payment did go
down but I'm planning on that's not
solving the problem you just move the
money around
yeah so I was planning on just paying
more uh than my monthly plan payment was
just to add up um some extra or take off
some time to pay it off okay do you have
any other debt
uh no sir okay are you driving for FedEx
or are you uh in an office or a
warehouse I work at the airport so no
I'm not driving okay uh George I would I
would like to see him you know he
doesn't have a lot of time
but I'd like to see I I'd like to see
him change his budget so radically that
he can get not upside down so get on the
right side of this thing and then sell
the car and go with a three or four
thousand dollar car yeah is that too
extreme well we say if you can't pay off
the car within two years then we got to
sell the car right it's just too much of
your world wrapped up in this thing and
your future is too important for you to
just have these payments you're sending
out on top of the spending habits and
all of a sudden man you're making great
money you got nothing to show for it and
part of that is the debt part of it's
the spending we can get both under
control uh one of those ways is through
a budget which it doesn't sound like
you're doing right now when we want to
help with that I'm going to gift you one
year of every dollar premium if you're
willing to use it are you willing to get
on a plan yes sir okay so when you open
up every dollar you're going to list
your income at the top followed by all
of your expenses and here's the thing
you are the boss of that budget and when
it's done it's the boss of you
yeah and so what that means is once you
set it you go man I am not spending more
than 200 on food this month on I'm not
spending more than 70 on entertainment
this month that means when your friends
ask you out say hey dude come out with
us you go sorry dude it's not on the
budget and they're gonna say dude you're
so lame man you get a lot and you're
gonna say that's cool uh you guys can
come to my place we can get some pizzas
and just hang out
and if they say no to that it may be
time to find better friends if they're
just unwilling to to compromise and
cheer you on with your financial journey
and uh with every dollar I'm gonna gift
you FPU I think going through that will
motivate you because you need a
long-term why right now you're a young
guy you're driven already the fact that
you're at this place in life but if you
have a long-term mindset I want 29 year
old Jonathan to be proud of the
decisions that 19 year old Jonathan made
yeah that's a different mindset to have
because most people your age are
thinking about next weekend not 10 years
from now
yeah by the way Jonathan that's
incredible advice and that's what you're
going to have to have at the top of your
mind and you need a true visual of what
George is talking about where do you
want to be at 29 get a clear I mean
crystal clear image of that and when
your buddies start giving you a hard
time come on man let's go man let's go
to the club blah blah blah whatever it
is they say these days so the kids go to
the club I don't know I'm I'm so old I
don't even know but I'm not even sure
where the voice came from but the point
is is the ability to say no
only comes from
a decision that is made much earlier
and you make that decision and then you
manage that decision every time you're
tempted you make the big decisions early
in life
and then you manage those decisions the
rest of your life a lot of wisdom in
that Ken well thank you so much for the
call Jonathan hang on the line we're
going to gift you one year of Financial
Peace University as well as every dollar
premium get your friends involved get
them on the plan too man
yeah they're all broke all right we're
gonna go to Robert and Boise uh let's go
Robert how's it going with you
that's good how can we help today
okay so
um I had a tsp question all right or
actually two questions about the Thrift
Savings Plan
um I retired last December congrats from
um thank you uh worked at the border
patrol for 21 years wow but
since then
um because of covid and because of uh
backlogs of people retiring
I haven't got my full pension yet it's
been almost almost 12 months so I'm
getting a partial so right now between
child support and rent
I'm coming out at zero so I'm trying not
to dip into my PSP
at all if I can help it because it's
it's taking a hit over the last year or
so so it's drastically reduced and then
I've got friends who are taking that tsp
and going to like a private someone I
don't know like linking Financial or
someone where they can still play with
it and make some money
I gotta just kind of sitting there doing
nothing right now
okay so questions are uh do I dip into
it because I got to pay some bills I'm
I'm going to bet further and further
using credit cards and everything
waiting for the government to come
through with my full pension and the
second part is do I shift it over to a
private company where I can possibly
make money on it
well number one on my tsp I I never wait
on the government to do anything in my
life because you're going to be waiting
a long time as you know so number one
I'm cutting up the cards and they're
just debt is not going to be an option
and uh if we need to adjust the budget
if we need to go get a get some work
right now even though we're retired I'm
gonna do that to stop the bleeding
number two I wouldn't just jump out of
the tsp and go play with it elsewhere in
the private sector I don't think that's
why it's easier either now you can if
you need some of it to live right now
that's okay
but I would be working with a financial
advisor you can connect with a
smartvester pro those are the ones that
we vet over at ramseysolutions.com we've
got some in the Boise area who can walk
you through the best decision to make
with that chunk of money that you have
in the tsp if it's worth moving
somewhere else if you can make more
elsewhere
um but I would not just go cash it out
to survive because you're not stopping
the actual Behavior that's causing us to
to feel this pain
right right
okay I'm sorry you're going through this
man that's tough to go I work 21 years
Ken and the government said they were
going to take care of me and here we are
and they're kicking the can down the
road that frustrates me to no end and I
hate that you may have to go back to
work for a little bit to make ends meet
but man that credit card is a rubber
crutch it's not setting up for Success
it's not a blessing in your life cut it
up get on a budget use that debit card
and we hope that you win in retirement
and live your best life thanks for the
call man this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
just got back from our Building Wealth
event in Minneapolis it was a powerful
night sold out 5 000 folks out there
incredible energies so good wish we
could do those every night there's a lot
going on right now the midterms are
wrapping up inflation's still hanging
around stock market's a roller coaster
but that's exactly why we are out on the
road doing these Building Wealth live
events we want people to know regardless
of what's going on in the white house
there is a way to take care of your own
house and build wealth for your future
and our Building Wealth live events have
been such a hit that last week we added
more cities to our spring lineup it's
going to be me Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz
Ken Coleman Dr John deloney we're going
to be in Nashville on January 12th in
Salt Lake City Home event a little
Hometown show okay I like that good to
go in January okay and Salt Lake City on
April 24th and tickets are on sale right
now and they start at just 39 bucks and
you don't want to wait to get these
passes because our other events have
sold out very quickly especially the VIP
level passes and general admission is
moving fast as well so quick recap on
where we've been where we're headed
Nashville January 12th Indianapolis on
February 16th Austin Texas on February
23rd I love Austin Salt Lake City on
April 24th and Anaheim on May 2nd we're
going all over the country and we love
meeting folks out there and people
travel from all over the country to even
get to these events yeah we have people
that will drive hours and hours through
the night get on planes and we so
appreciate all of that so head to
ramseysolutions.com events and reserve
your seat for our Building Wealth live
tour today
all right our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why they are the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping with new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more be sure to use the promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from Clinton in Texas
should I leave my two hundred thousand
dollar a year offshore oilfield job at
age 41 to live my dream of being a
charter boat captain in the Caribbean I
loathe my job by the way that's a word
that we should use more loathe Loth is
is a great substitute for hate and it'll
score you some points uh just for
Quality we're just that's a little
commercial I loathe my job and even
though I only started saving four years
ago thanks to Dave's videos I have saved
wait for it George just over 500
000 between retirement non-retirement
counts wow but I loathe my job two
loaves plus three he wins a prize yeah
uh he says he's currently living on his
38-foot sailboat debt free and he's
obtained his U.S Coast Guard Master's
license I'm eagerly my job ahead South
for the Caribbean
um I'm committed to putting 20 000 a
year in a universal life policy until
I'm 55. don't do that George will give
you more on that which I feel is an easy
task uh blah blah blah blah blah so
let's get to this
okay Clinton I think it's an easy answer
here Ken it's a very easy answer all
right it's time to get out the captain's
hat
it's time to put it on the head and it's
time to head down to the warm Waters and
Breeze of the Caribbean I love this dude
you've done the hard work yeah you got
500 000 saved you're going to make
really good money you got no debt the
only issue I take with this entire thing
is the universal life policy agreed so
George while I'm picking out a captain's
hat for him in my mind and you know some
Tommy Bahama shirts I mean I'm I'm
picturing the whole thing Captain
Clinton oh what are you going to tell
him about the whole life yeah well he
said he's been watching Dave's videos
but he hasn't been watching closely
enough or watching them enough George is
no need to be snarky this let's this
come on Captain Clinton here out of all
the things in the financial world yeah
these Universal Life policies Whole Life
policies they drive me bonkers and
they're always pushed but I guess who
the whole life sales people right and
here's what the problem with this in
general they go well Ken you could use
your life insurance policy as an
investment vehicle and make so much
money tell me more George well they take
all of your giant premiums they charge
you they put that in their pocket and
then they give you a crappy investment
return
with these cash value parts of the
policy so here's what you do instead
instead of putting 20K a year in a
universal life policy get a term life
policy for 15 20 25 year term level term
and it's going to be a fraction of the
cost and with all the extra money you
just saved invest that money
and you'll be way better off don't
listen I don't know who sold you on this
man but you're a sharp guy and you don't
you do not need to be sinking nope no
pun intended there Ken I think you did
there 20K a year and I'd add one other
thing if I could Captain Clinton uh when
you get to the Caribbean email George
and I uh tell us where your charter boat
is with a photo give us a special
discount for our incredible advice that
we've given you and we'll do a camel
Coleman vacation we'll take the wives
down there and we'll get out there on
the boat with Captain Clinton so let's
deserve it yeah a little catamaran maybe
you ever done one of those no it's
another great word nobody uses catamaran
gosh I tell you what George nobody
loathes being on a catamaran you listen
to this show and Ken will teach you
about 17 new 10 words that he's got in
his back pocket yeah you win at work Ken
is wealthy when it comes to vocabulary
didn't have a TV till I was 12. and it
shows read a lot of books and it shows
all right let's get to some calls uh
Kevin is in Minneapolis okay Evan how
are you were you at the event
I'm outstanding your don't let anybody
give you crap about the Mall of America
and uh can your your cardigan game is
strong okay context there we need to
explain to the audience what Kevin is
talking about Ken was wearing a cashmere
cardigan and John deloney was dogging
him the whole night because John is
jealous that John only wears shirts you
get at Hot Topic and so when you wear a
cashmere or anything it throws John off
and that doesn't even know how to spell
cashmere while in Minneapolis me and our
Ramsey personality Eddie Cullen went to
the Mall of America to see what it was
all about Rachel called you out on the
panel and mentioned that and we got
Flack for that and so thank you for that
Kevin I appreciate that hope you had a
great time at the event last night
fantastic and and it's ironic that you
just plugged it but anyone who can get
to these events it's life-changing um I
was able to bring my wife she wasn't on
board the whole Ramsey
ish stuff and we'll that'll be my
question but just real quick gratitude
um borrowed future gave me a moment with
my 18 year old daughter that probably
changed her her life permanently and I
just want to say thank you so much oh
man that warms our heart thank you for
that Kevin
absolutely happy to hear that really it
was it was fantastic my wife like I said
I'm total Ramsay Kool-Aid drinking
person I love it maybe that's not the
best reference but
my question is now that she's kind of
getting into this and I'm I'm ready to
and it's kind of been a Hot Topic where
I'll do anything I'm ready to quit my
jobs just to get to baby step three
um last night Dave created a crystal
clear image of where he was walking out
of a job because I don't have any more
payments that's my dream I want to get
to that point but my fear is if I just
go works you know to do anything make as
much money as possible then I might get
burnt out you know um what would you
tell someone like that that you know
you're we've got a DARS in club
volleyball it's very expensive Kevin
Kevin I'm sorry to interrupt is your
question should you get a better paying
job right now that you may not really be
in love with just to fast forward
through the baby steps is that your
question kind of I love what I do I have
two jobs one job as well the other job I
love and doesn't pay very much at all so
what do I do yes kind of well then I
would stay in the job you love but I
would bust my butt and I would go make
much better money on the side hustle
let's get gazelle intense but I would
not leave the job I love unless I can
replace that with another job I love
that makes me even more money does that
make sense okay
yes so I mean this is busted let's just
get after it anyway it comes to baby
step two with uh what do I do with a
spouse who's got you know Ramsay ish
well number one I would encourage you
guys to go through Financial Peace
University I know you heard about that
last night but that's one of the ways
you you create a common shared language
you create common goals you create a
vision that most married couples have
never taken the time to do and so when
you position it that way it's not about
well Dave said we can't go out to eat
it's hey we decided our future is too
important to continue down this path and
so that becomes a different conversation
great and that's the other thing and I
would just say Kevin that this is not a
I'm this and she's that and I'm not
getting on you and I don't think that
your heart's that way but this is about
Vision casting and so taking the classes
but then helping her see this isn't
about me getting all excited about this
dude named Dave Ramsey and getting all
crazy no this is yeah allowing us to to
accomplish the desired future that we
long for it's Vision casting I love it
take her on a date and say this is our
future this is where we're headed bring
her along into it let her dream too it's
not just your dream that you're dragging
her that's never going to work in a
marriage and so once you do that you go
through fbu I think over time she sees
that this plan works she gets fired up
man
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
15 13 there is no greater love than to
lay down one's life for one's friends
George Washington once said the
willingness with which our young people
are likely to serve in any war no matter
how Justified shall be directly
proportional to how they perceive the
veterans of earlier wars were treated
and appreciated by their Nation
man beautiful words they don't they
don't make them like they used to Ken
that's
and uh quickly I want to give some
context for Veterans Day because there's
a lot of Mythology around there the
purposes of Veterans Day versus Memorial
Day often get mixed up
and here's the difference Veterans Day
honors all who have served and are still
with us while Memorial Day remembers
those who have lost their lives in
service to our great nation and both
days are hard for veterans because on
both occasions there are reminders of
their fellow servicemen and women the
ones they've lost the ones they couldn't
save the ones that couldn't save
themselves and if you know a veteran
you've got one in your life understand
this is a day of mixed emotions of Pride
and loss so please be sure to thank them
today love on them today and their
response may feel short as it can be
uncomfortable being thanked for
something they felt was a duty to their
country and was an honor for them to be
a part of but showing that you care
enough to give a simple thanks does go a
long long way Ken yeah it reminds me my
grandfather growing up he left Pearl
Harbor six months almost to the day of
the bombing wow at Pearl Harbor and uh
anytime he would be honored on Veterans
Day and he would get a little teary
thinking of some of the men that some of
his friends that stayed in the service
at that time and lost their lives on
that fateful day so it's a very good
call out and again I think one of the
things that would be good for all of us
and specifically young people is making
sure that young people in our lives
understand the value of today this is
not National pretzel day it's Veterans
Day and we derive great liberties from
the men and women who are courageous
enough to put their life on the line say
Amen big day yeah it definitely it gives
me pause and causes me to be extremely
grateful for those men and women so
thank you for that and happy Veterans
Day to you all out there all right let's
go to the phones David joins us up next
in Salt Lake City David welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey thank you for having me I've uh I
really appreciate uh you guys the whole
Ramsey team I've learned a ton over the
last few months since I started
listening to you sure um and uh really
appreciate your your appreciation of
veterans too and helping them out so
thank you how can we help today
yeah so
um I was listening last week and and uh
David mentioned on the show that um
there our caller had mentioned that uh
on your site it says that for stocks you
should invest in kind of four buckets
growth and income growth aggressive
growth and international and
um so it gives on the on the website it
gives kind of
um I guess an alias for growth and
income which would be large cap and or
Blue Chip and and so on it kind of
describes the other three buckets a
little bit better but International it
doesn't really say
what you would suggest investing in as
far as the international bucket goes and
I'm looking at my my 529 options and
there's six different options
um like like growth value
um uh developed Market Emerging Market
uh stock index and so I just I was
wondering what would be good because I
want to have a good investment in my my
529 and my 401k and I also max out my
HSA and I want to invest anything after
uh you know what I need for my
deductible way to go man you are so far
ahead of the curve it is inspiring so
you're doing a great job and the fact
that you're asking these kinds of
questions tell me that you are going to
win when it comes to money so with
international funds what you're looking
for here is a proven track record so
it's not that there's a specific company
and when you say stocks I want to make
it clear to everyone listening we are
not talking about single stocks in an
international company like Samsung we're
talking about mutual funds that rep
represent shares of many many companies
inside of that International fund and so
that's what we're talking about here to
be clear and you're right there's a lot
of options and I you know there's so
many different types of accounts and
every company has different funds and it
depends on what you're looking at
and so do you have a good financial
advisor a good smart investor Pro in
your life that's walking you through
some of these decisions
not currently I was I was kind of
holding off on it a little bit but yeah
I mean I could definitely uh you know
look into a smart investor Pros just
trying to kind of watch costs right now
so sure well you know they're not going
to charge you a fee just for sitting
there but what they can do is work with
you to look at hey this is what my
options are show me how to even do the
research on these funds and you can use
a site like Morningstar and you can type
in the names of those funds and it will
show you exactly what the track record
is what the mix of stocks that are in
there what the makeup is and that really
helps you make a long-term decision of
course you're looking for one with a
long-term track record and so not just
what has happened in the last six months
but over the last 10 years what is this
fund done you might see oh one's 12
average return and so you start to look
at the in the ins and outs of that and
it will help steer you in a Direction
but at the end of the day don't get
paralyzed by indecision on this go with
a fund ride the roller coaster and the
fact you're even investing in a
diversified fund like that will cause
you to have long-term success so I love
that you're doing that homework and
again I would connect with a smart
investor Pro
I have one Ken has one Dave has one
Rachel has one and they help us because
they are doing this kind of research day
in and day out of what's going on with
these funds what's changed which ones we
should be putting our money towards so I
love the question thanks for that
Jessica joins us up next in Indianapolis
Jessica welcome to the show
hey guys thanks so much yeah how can we
help you
yeah I'll try and be quick here to my
point
um so I've been uh aware of Ramsay and
all this stuff for several years
um but I really I haven't had the
opportunity to implement it myself just
because of not always being the one in
charge of the money
um and now I don't have an income
personally myself two example how great
this program is but I believe it 100 I
personally am debt-free I want to get my
family on board I come from an
Incredible family
um hard workers but not good with money
management and so they struggle
constantly it impacts the whole family
I have I think I am starting to kind of
get there a little bit with them but my
dad and my brother their words are
always that basically people with money
can do this but people who don't have
money can't do it and I keep trying to
like show them but since I can't do the
example myself quite yet in life
um I have had my parents mention that
maybe they would let me help them with
their finances but they haven't taken
the full week and so I really want to
get them on board with this but
I guess I'm just looking for some advice
of um
how
well the best way is your own personal
testimony of you living out this plan
them seeing the results in them over
time it's on their end they go hey would
you what are you doing there because it
seems like you've got a different thing
happening you're joyful you're peaceful
you don't have any debt tell me about
that but you can't force someone to just
get on board because I don't have an
income myself and I can't wait yeah why
is that why is that we only have about a
minute and a half why is that you said
that multiple times
yeah because
um I have a disability that doesn't
allow me to work and I've not been able
to get disability at this point are you
single um
uh recently divorced okay okay so you
don't have disability income how are you
paying the bills
well currently I'm living off of
um the money from the divorce but yeah
it won't be around for long so we need
to get you back to work that you're able
to do
they said that question would be too
long for this call okay okay that's for
another day but as far as getting the
family on board I mean you can talk to
them about it but again if it's not on
their terms they're gonna say we don't
want to hear about this Dave guy and so
the best thing you can do is find their
pain points what is their true felt need
are they stressed out about money and
you go hey would you mind I just want to
I'm just gonna take a look at your
budget I'm not gonna tell you what to do
I just want to look at it and see if
there's other areas I can find to help
you experience a little bit of peace and
if you can give them a taste of what
that is they may go oh tell me more and
that might mean
to do but I'm kind of like I don't
really since I haven't been able to
implement the program myself like I
don't really know if I look at their
income that I'm gonna know what to tell
them to do well that's probably fair and
I got to tell you even if they were to
give you permission to manage their
money you shouldn't do that they're
grown they're they're your parents get
them the books gift them our stuff but
don't take the burden of no this is my
job fix their financial life that's a
disaster waiting to happen yeah that's a
tough one well thank you so much for the
call that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books Ken what a great show
my friend always good to be with you
always a pleasure until next time folks
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]